I think Facebook is responsible of what
exists and what happens on its platform
and I think that Facebook has been
negligent in its responsibility to
safeguarding and providing a forum in
which sane and reasonable interaction
happens and that hysterical and untrue
interaction does not happen what we know
is that Facebook has the ability to deal
with with fake news these are fake sites
then they pop up there being spread by
specific pages and specific accounts and
rather than address that Facebook is
allowed millions of people to become
deeply ill in the form now there's a
question how how democratic she shoot a
platform like Facebook be if everyone
wants to share a fake news article
should that be allowed or does Facebook
have some editorial control of what it
allows to be propagated via its own its
own mechanism isn't its own channels I
mean I think the Facebook needs to take
greater steps in these spaces because
again Facebook itself has become a media
publisher and it is now the platform in
the canvas for chaos to be created by
all of this fake information spreading
so quickly without any check-in balance
and any responsibility being taken by
the platform of sorting through what is
true and what is not I mean I think
there has to be some editorial
infrastructure and they've had in the
past some editorial infrastructure they
at one time had a staff that was
figuring out what should be in the
trending news and what should not and
immediately after they stopped got rid
of that staff all of a sudden there was
a bunch of fake news in the trending
right now we one obvious step but but I
also think that there has to be Facebook
has remarkable power through its
algorithms and through its media
partnerships to make decisions about
what becomes prominent on its site and
what does not there's certainly an
organic Democratic role to this but it's
not as if they are just completely
sitting back and playing no role over
what we see and what we do not and if
it's the beginning as soon as they begin
playing that role at all they now take
on I believe a responsibility to curate
this content I think I said I just think
it's extremely damaging you think about
newspapers and newspapers don't run
every letter they get there's a decision
there's a curation right we decide this
is this one is just a rambling that has
nothing to do with anything this is
just full of falsehoods right when you
choose to publish something on your
platform on your canvas you are making
an editorial decision to allow it to
exist in the space Facebook can takes
down threatening and abusive things all
the time it takes down personal attacks
or or nudity or Prague Rafi right it has
the ability when you have specific
publishers that are constantly spreading
misinformation it has some ability to
undercut those publishers from from
further spreading them